on commence à soupçonner didier de faire
des fausses citations de va qui lève la
main mais c'est lui qui servent juste
sur ces troubles
c'est très troublant tu as eric books
que vous adorez non vraiment je suis un
grand fan des noms mais je sais elle est
intelligente cultivée sexy sympa mais en
fait la question quand tu as un enfant
tue le prépare à l'est dans la vie tu
lui apprend à marcher avec toi son père
en td est ce que tu lui a appris à
marcher à ce qu'elle peut se lancer seul
voilà c'est toi qui dois je vais la
donner après je vais donner mon avis
aussi aux eric soit éric voilà en tout
cas là tout sourit interviewer et voilà
c'est ça c'est souris tu as l'air
emmerder de répondre wells au maire
[Applaudissements]
alors bien sûr dire ce que je pense
d'abord à la fin vous bientôt